interrogé sur ce consentement jeu vers
celle que nous dit moi j'ai rappelé à la
biopolitique du coronavirus que nous dit
le coronavirus c'est que la société
moderne la société consumériste nous
fait une promesse à wau homme je vais
vivre à 76 77 ans statistiquement femme
je vais vivre jusqu'à 80 à 82 cents
statistiquement si je meurs avant il ya
un truc qui a cloché dans le système
donc je demande à ce que le système
c'est ce que moi j'ai appelé là d'une
politique de couronnes à dégelis le
système me protège me surprotège en
étouffant au restaurant récents en
diminuant les libertés et vous parlez
des marottes je pense qu est ce qui nous
manque en jeu insiste sur le congélateur
je pense que ces centrales le
congélateur
mais c'est une obsession célinienne
pourquoi si on s'intéresse à la france
périphérique à la france de gilet jaune
pour de bon et pas de loi ce que nous
montre fourques et est cassée lit c'est
qu'est ce que font ces gens là c'est
pour ça qu'ils font pas de risque c'est
que la fin du mois se termine le 25 ils
passent leur temps à faire le plein le
plainte de la bagnole le plein du tabac
à rouler le père du caddie et surtout le
plein du congélateur il ya un mythe
tenue congélateur alors la barre à
écrire dans la france périphérique dans
la france pas visionnaire pas donc ça
chacun sa marotte sablon si on veut
parler de cette france là dans des
catégories populaires et des classes et
faut s'intéresser à la baguette à 29
centimes faut s'intéresser au
congélateur c'est le congélateur
l'obsession c'est le congélateur pas
logique
[Musique]